I've noted an increase of tick-tock ads
that are selling Medical Products here's
a list of ones that I would never buy
some of them downright dangerous check
it out
did you know
I love the tick tocks that tell me did I
know like I didn't go to medical school
your cells are rapidly aging because of
constant exposure to technology I got a
revelation for you at home did you know
you were aging
do you use technology do not use
technology you're still aging this
device creates a coherent protective
shield
[Music]
coherent I am so honored to offer this
scientifically proven EMF mitigation
device
man people are really using
scientifically proven in a in a weak way
these days it creates harmonic field in
your environment reaching 100 feet in
all directions it creates a harmonic
field reaching a hundred feet in all
directions penetrating through walls and
floors and it goes through walls and
Floors it restructures water it
restructures water this is the most
miraculous lamp or I don't even know
what is this the improved sleep focus
and energy why do I go to work when I
could just put this up on on the display
and just have the patients hang out in
the room with this thing I need to look
this up like where do they sell this two
thousand dollars improved sleep more
energy better concentration improved
hydration reduce stress and anxiety
fewer headaches enhanced physical
recovery
first of all let me woosa and relax it
says it creates a 360 degree coherent
field of a hundred feet in all
directions penetrating through walls of
force what's hilarious is I don't know
what a coherent field of 100 feet mean I
think they just say words calms the
parasympathetic nervous system and then
it's it's a little asterisk and it says
these statements have not been evaluated
for medical accuracy yeah no oh my God
oh my God oh my God elimination of
influences of 5G geopathic zones I don't
even know what a geopathic zone is a
hundred percent water structuring decade
plus of Education don't know what any of
these words mean and the device itself
is just Stones say goodbye double chin a
hundred times a day okay this is some
kind of sucking device see the problem
with this product is that it's trying to
make you believe that there's such thing
as spot reduction there is no such thing
if I lower my overall body fat content
then I can see more muscle but if I just
work out my biceps I'm not going to just
see fat reduction on the biceps it
doesn't work that way because your body
works as a unit as opposed to individual
pieces and that's what essentially
they're saying when they say remove the
double chin here we have another video
of it how to get a Slimmer face quickly
again ridiculous promises I mean look at
that image they're literally taking
someone who's posing in a uncomfortable
position that's not normal for them and
then they have them stand up straight
that is not what happens look like even
if you pull up this thing on Walmart
reduces the appearance of wrinkles well
not at all because wrinkles are formed
for muscle usage in fact when we inject
Botox to prevent or get rid of wrinkles
we're trying to relax the muscle to
paralyze the muscle releases any tension
in the face how do you strengthen them
muscle and release tension firms and
tightens the facial skin how skin is
taught because of skin molecules and
skin proteins not because of muscle so
like a lot of promises a lot of
statements it's not a miracle slimming
device that it claims A Change Your Life
Hack and health hack again big promises
let's see what we got so this machine
produces seven different Waters okay so
there's a there's different PHS of
waters I don't know why you'd want
certain PHS of waters medically but
let's see I'm going to be non-judgmental
but what's also cool is it boosts the
molecular hydrogen in these three
drinking Waters so drinking two glasses
of this water is equivalent to eating
five pounds yes five pounds of
blueberries what are we talking about
when you consume water that has a pH of
9.5 which means that it's it's a basic
pH not acidic alkaline when it dumps
itself through the esophagus into the
stomach do you know what the pH is
that's chilling in the stomach two very
acidic environments it's called gastric
acid for a reason and then when you
drink this pH water of 9.5 what do you
think happens do you think it stays
alkaline no it becomes acidic and it
mixes with this thing and then what
happens is when you drink the water and
your body absorbs the water you think
your blood concentrations of acid base
is not incredibly tightly managed it's
so managed that your blood pH has to
stay between 7.35 and 7.45 otherwise you
die this is my favorite it also makes
beauty water Beauty water my God I
guarantee you this device is like 10
grand
the bottom line is none of these things
are proven by real Medical Science
everything is over promised over hyped
and it's not because I'm saying we know
more or doctors no more it's that we
know what we don't know
and they refuse to admit that they don't
know there's a big problem stop
fingering your ears first of all uh yeah
jamming your finger in your ear is not a
good idea so this is starting off well
use this ear camera instead oh just
connect it to your phone put it in your
ear okay so this device it looks cool it
looks technological and it actually
works meaning that like you could see
the inside of your ear with your camera
because it works through Bluetooth but
this is a terrible product and I'll tell
you why terrible in the sense of how
people are using it people think that
this product is great for cleaning ears
then they go inside their ears with no
training and start scratching up their
ear canals busting their tympanic
membranes yes their eardrums we're
seeing this in our offices plus I don't
really understand the obsession of
removing earwax from the inside of your
ear if it's clogged you could put ear
drops in they sell them over the counter
it'll melt the earwax they'll come out
and earwax is good for your ear it
actually traps dust bacteria it even
protects the canal if there's a little
moisture in there from your your skin
getting irritated there's actually no
good medical utility that the average
person should have this in their home I
have it in my home I remember when Jen
Selter came over and she had an ear plug
that fell apart in her ear and I as a
medical professional was able to use
this tool but I would not recommend
anyone having this at home remove that
ear wax for better hearing and if your
hearing is not good you should get
evaluated by a doctor because it's not
always because of earwax there's true
issues with hearing especially these
days with everyone blasting their music
with earbuds that literally could be
early hearing loss and that's a real
problem that's why I really recommend
not listening to your music over 50 60
max volume how do I increase my height
one inch I can see how already this is
this is drawing people in because
everyone wants to be taller not everyone
a lot of people want to be taller this
posture corrector is pure magic it
depends what your definition of pure
magic is it's certainly not my
definition as a doctor because posture
correctors largely are unnecessary and
potentially harmful because the goal of
having good posture is about creating a
good natural posture when you're putting
on a device to create good posture
you're essentially weakening the muscles
that create good posture and you become
dependent on a device like this there's
a lot of information out there about
like posture needs to be perfect you
don't always need to sit up perfectly
like this like it's okay to lean back if
you're tired but it's about having good
solid strength for your posture in order
for you to be able to sit comfortably
and not have to slouch over like this or
have a forward shoulder rounded posture
so like these things are far from Magic
and actually in many cases do more harm
than good mastic has been grown in
Greece and chewed for thousands of years
as the original natural chewing gum as a
doctor I was not trained to answer this
question so I can't fact check that but
mastic is I think some kind of resin
sculpt your jawline results within the
first week a hundred percent natural
true discrete exercise size program
gluten allergen free not for the not for
the week can you imagine a less
motivating product than a product that's
encouraging you to get strong but is
saying it's not for the week how does
that make sense from an advertising
perspective I don't like a lot of these
products where you're chewing very
heavily because you're using the
masseter jaw muscle yes but remember a
lot of the shape that comes from your
jawline doesn't come from the muscle it
comes from the bone and structure that's
already formed has nothing to do with
the muscle so yeah while you can
exercise the muscle you could also over
exercise this muscle do you know what
happens when you have a sore masseter
pain in the TMJ area grinding at night
while you're sleeping so many issues can
arise when it comes to dental care when
you have an overtrained masseter I would
not recommend this product even just the
claim not for the week tells you all you
need to know our included workout
program will leave your jaw feeling
exhausted after the first day not for
the week this is another piece of
information when you start a new
exercise routine the goal isn't to
exhaust you to break your muscles down
so much so that you can't perform the
next day the goal is to give you an
appropriate stimulus to get your muscles
to perform better the next time not
destroy them that's a big mistake that
not only marketing companies clearly
make but also personal trainers
coffee enemas boost glue
glutathione production by 700x and detox
deliver
I can't fact check the glutathione
production because I don't know exactly
what they're saying and that would
require some serious fact checking but
what I can tell you with very good
certainty is that coffee enemas do not
detox the liver deliver itself is one of
your detoxification organs on its own so
you don't need to detox your liver oh my
God so this is like an at-home enema kit
that you hang in your shower animatip
soft silicone easy to insert only goes
in about two inches if it's not
necessary medically inserting this tube
can already cause problems if you have a
hemorrhoid it can cause bleeding you
could cause an anal fissure and
inserting any kind of fluid into your
abdomen into your gut there can cause
problems infection diarrhea even like
legitimate rectal problems
morning coffee enema the gut one way in
one way out why are we changing the flow
why are we saying let's put the coffee
on the bottom instead of the top I don't
get it instant bloating and constipation
relief look if you want to use a regular
enema because you're experiencing
constipation that's a different thing
but like using it daily to detox your
body is just not true the body does this
naturally great for skin and hormones
too like we're just throwing in a lot of
false promises here just to do this for
health reasons is a full-on lie and
people are tricking you and it's sad to
see that Tick Tock doesn't actively take
this stuff down ionic foot detox oh this
is BS here's what happens in these clips
person puts their feet in this thing it
starts changing colors and here we go
watercolor it starts telling you what's
wrong with you this is my favorite this
is so ridiculous
bubbles equals gas and bloating uh-huh
maybe inside your gut but not in here
this has actually been unraveled as one
of the biggest most embarrassing sources
of disinformation not even
misinformation as you could see in this
Inside Edition clip where they expose
these foot bath scams we bought our own
foot bath unit and had it tested by
Stephen Fowler an electrical engineer
through electrolysis they run a current
through this water everything you see
here is just rust when you run the
electricity through that water your body
has electrolytes on your skin salt right
every time you sweat and as a result it
starts changing colors and depending how
long you run it for it's also going to
have different colors and check this out
those supposed toxins appear even
without feed in the water it is nothing
but a scam this serves as an example as
to how the entire industry Works they
see some kind of medical terminology
that they understand stand what that
terminology is they don't have enough
understanding to know where their
limitations lie and they start over
promising you stuff and charging you
huge sums of money for it you're at risk
because you want to stay healthy maybe
your doctor recommends something for you
to do that requires a lot of work time
energy and you say why would I do that
when I can do this I'm feeling slow
heavy and for 115 it can improve it let
me do it it's BS and this proves it
right here how about some good and
dangerous medical products from Shark
Tank click here to check that out and as
always stay happy and healthy I wear a
suit charcoalski check it out
[Music]
foreign